okay i get this question all the time is
being a good poker player a prerequisite
for being a good startup investor great
question uh
yeah um poker is
very analogous to
investing in startups because you have
partial information i know my two cards
let's say the flop has come out i know
those three cards
i know that it was 200 dollars because
it was a 100 200 game and to see the
flop it wasn't raised but you did have
to put the 200 blinds in so i know the
four players who did see the flop
one of them was the big blind they were
already in for 200. one of them was in
for 100 small blind they put another 100
in and then two people
put 200 in so they might have had
relatively
good hands or maybe they're a little
frisky and they want to see a flop or
they like their position
so you're kind of trying to piece
together what's happening from the
behavior and the information as it
unfolds in real time and then you have a
layer of it that's math
so you're placing a bet okay i'm going
to place this bet well what is my
expected return and um
do i have uh is it worth me being in the
hand so you know i've got 10 jack and oh
i hit my 10 and the board's ace
you know queen
jack and i have 10 jack okay i've got
the bottom pair for king comes they hit
the straight but oh my goodness like
ace queen there's two cards over cards
that are better than mine somebody could
have ace queen somebody raises somebody
re-raises and now i'm looking at this
information and going is my bottom pair
good and my gut shot straight draw good
probably not
probably i don't have the best hand here
what am i playing for
what's the best i'm gonna do in fact
that king does come and i hit my
straight does somebody else also have a
straight somebody have a set right now
like you probably
um
if you've experienced poker that's why i
think a lot of people should play poker
is because you
get to learn in real time
to figure out what's happening and then
you have to develop a strategy
based on what you're figuring out so
you're not just figuring it out in the
abstract you have to be a strategy and
then you have to place a bet or fold you
either have to commit to the startup or
pass so that is also analogous you have
to decide with this hand
also analogous you don't have to win
every hand you don't have to play every
hit you don't have to play every night
you could sit out for a month you could
play every hand you could place five
bets in a row so
the betting strategy also very important
and then
you know i didn't hit twitter i didn't
hit zynga
and i didn't hit dollar shave club i
missed all of those and i ran into the
ceo of dollar shave club of that and he
reminded me of that last night and we
had a funny laugh about it um because he
wanted me to be a seat investor and i
was like listen kid razors will never be
anything let me give you a piece of
advice build a software company and he
was like okay boomer
that's another 50 million mistake on my
part um
but i didn't have to win that pot
because i won the uber pot the com pot
the grin pot the you know
[Music]
robin hood pot the thumbtack pot like
that's the point you you can you can win
another pot and do just fine then
finally there's something called
bankroll management
so you go to a poker game when i played
in la there were people at the game who
were very intense like more intense than
they should be and i was like how is
this person in a ten thousand dollar
buy-in poker game and it's a hundred two
hundred dollars and they're in for 30-40
grand can if they lose 30-40 grand can
they pay this and you know i talked to
the host and they're like yeah you know
the guy's worth a hundred grand and i'm
like i got 40 of his net worth on the
table
really uh and then you know when you
when i play with my friends in silicon
valley
kind of similar stakes and that doesn't
represent but
you know a fraction fraction fraction of
one percent of people's net worth
so that is called bankroll management
how much are you willing to put at risk
of your total amount of money well
that's your fund
so if you have uh launch fund three is a
44 million dollar fund if
i'm not putting 44 million dollars in
one company i might put four million
that'd be a big bet right that would be
like the biggest bet we make i might put
a million into a company 500k 250k but
i'm thinking about bankroll management
how do i manage that 44 million to
deploy it intelligently over time to get
the best return for my investors so
bankroll management another concept and
then there's reading people so there's a
fourth or fifth way that poker is very
similar um and then there's managing
your own psychology which is probably a
sixth way that it's like poker
you ever play poker or do any kind of
gambling and you
you know let's just take roulette you're
betting on black and you go to a table
that's got seven reds in a row because
you know they show you how what the last
numbers were seven reds in a row and you
bet
500 bucks 500 bucks 500 bucks 500 bucks
500 bucks and seven more reds come out
and it's 14 reds in a row and you're
like this is statistically not possible
but now you're out of money
and you're on tilt and so you decide to
take all your money out of your pocket
and put five thousand dollars on black
and it still comes out red
and uh you know then the
dealer or some other professional
gambler says to you like
each time that wheel spins it's still 48
48 or 50 50 or whatever the wheels odds
are to be black or red because there are
the green ones too but anyway just say
it's 50 50.
it doesn't matter what happened
previously
i mean we like to think that but
each time it's 50 50. so
you have to manage your own psychology i
think that's all i can tell you